I've just given a lecture here at the
federal university of rio de janeiro and
in the lecture theatre there's a most
fantastic periodic table which I just
wanted you to look at with me so here it
is and you can see you can see it's old
first of all because there's an old
spelling of the name
Mendeleev with two F's like on my
surname Polyakov but there are lots of
things that are really quite unusual
the first thing you might notice is that
it's in brazilian Brazilian Portuguese
and the second thing is that it has
right at the top where I can't reach it
has the neutron as the first element
next of the figure 1 and then we have on
the left hand side that the noble gases
they're normally on the right hand side
but the big surprise is if we walk over
to the right hand side there are the
noble gases again so they appear twice
and why I'm not sure I think perhaps
because they weren't sure whether it
should go under the neutron at the
beginning or at the end because the
electron shells were complete but like
many old periodic tables it's folded
back on itself so instead of having
transition metals in the middle they
appear over on this side so you can see
there's iron cobalt and nickel right on
the right-hand side but the thing that
has fascinated Brady and me is that some
of the names of the elements and their
symbols have changed so let's have a
look at some of them let's begin over
here this one here 87 which is francium
one of the most popular videos of ours
and it's got the symbol VI and neither
of us know what VI stands for and away
from the internet here we can't look it
up perhaps one of you can tell us what
it's meant to be then as we go across we
have over here element 41 niobium is
called CB which I think was called
columbium but I'm not certain and then
as we move across though there's another
one that I have noticed that's different
ma over here which is technetium
so I have no idea why it has been called
ma so there's another thing for you to
look up and tell us about then rather
more boring right at Pier number 18
argon is just a rotten AR and it was on
it was called a on some of the periodic
tables that I saw when I was a schoolboy
so that's perhaps less exciting and then
down here we have astatine which is
called a B again I'm not quite sure what
that stands for
and promethium which you may not be able
to see very well because it's rather
dirty is called il possibly ilium or
something like that but I'm not sure
professor you're a bit of a connoisseur
of periodic tables and you have a lot of
them in your office what do you think of
this one I think this one's terrific
never seen one like this before but I'm
not quite sure of the date but if you
look here it's got the element lynnium
and rhenium was only discovered in the
1920s so this means the periodic table
is older than the 1920s or perhaps the
late 1920s but on the other hand there
are no elements after uranium which
suggests that the periodic table this
periodic table was painted before the
Second World War
because after the Second World War
people knew about the elements neptunium
and plutonium if not all the others so
we can date it approximately somewhere
between 1930 1940 and the thing that I
particularly appreciate and so does
Brady is that at the last moment they
change the lecture theater where I was
going to give my talk so I could give it
in the one with this periodic table
because my host professor Rodrigo
thought that I would like it isn't that
right
and he was correct we got a whole new
video so thank you there there is a
little rhyme which begins with lanthanum
and it goes land language centers praise
made promise of small European garden
hubs dinosaurs Hubble erotically
thrumming yellow loops